oral questions questions the honorable
leader of the opposition
mr speaker i'd like to begin by sending
best wishes to the prime minister and
his children that are dealing with
covid19 as a family that had covid in
the home i wish them a speedy recovery
canadian manufacturer
canadian manufacturers the federation of
independent business the chamber of
commerce the conservative opposition
thousands of truckers for over a month
have proposed solutions to the trucking
shortage in canada and the supply chain
crisis mr speaker the prime minister has
ignored this crisis
and even worse he calls names for people
that are raising these very issues so mr
speaker my question is simple
will the prime minister move past the
division and agree to meet with some of
the truckers impacted by his federal
regulations
the right honorable prime minister
mr speaker the science is very clear the
best way through this pandemic is to get
people vaccinated that's how we end the
disruptions to our supply chains caused
by this global pandemic that's how we
get back to the things we love to do
that's why we've been unequivocal on the
need to get vaccinated and great news
canadians across the country stepped up
almost 90 percent of canadians are
vaccinated including almost 90 percent
of truckers because we know that the
biggest disruption to our supply chains
happens when people catch covet that's
why vaccinations are the way through it
and we're going to continue to be
unequivocal about that
the honorable leader of the opposition
mr speaker when you ignore and divide a
country when it needs to be united
that's not leadership mr speaker the
prime minister knows that the voices of
a few don't represent the millions of
canadians who are worried
millions of canadians over two years
have seen their lives upended their
children's mental health impacted
businesses fail mr speaker the nation
being stretched in our social fabric
vaccines are critically important but as
the prime minister's own covid diagnosis
demonstrates after three vaccinations we
have to use all tools mr speaker to get
our life back to normal when is life
getting back to normal mrs b right
honorable prime minister
i know and all canadians know how
frustrating it is to have to deal with
this pandemic uh for now two years uh
and ongoing
but canadians also have never been so
united in stepping up almost 90 percent
of canadians have been vaccinated and
that means uh they are protecting our
frontline health workers they are making
sure that we're getting through this as
best we possibly can it is that unity of
canadians that
nature that we have of being there for
each other that has been on such display
through this pandemic
yes there are people who are still
hesitant and yes there are people leader
the problem
foreign
[Applause]
people
mr speaker ukraine is an important
friend and ally to canada
our friends in ukraine are facing the
risk of a russian invasion as russian
troops gather at their border ukrainians
have seen this story before mr speaker
in crimea other nato allies are
delivering the military aid that ukraine
is requesting to help defend themselves
why won't this liberal government answer
the call from our friends in ukraine
[Music]
exactly what we've done in standing up
for ukraine unequivocally not just right
now but have been for the past many
years in my numerous conversations with
president zielinski uh in the
engagements that our ministers have had
in the region we have been listening to
ukraine in terms of what they most need
obviously we need to continue the
extraordinary trading mission that
canadians have been part of for many
many years and even increase it and also
uh we continue to deliver the aid
whether it's uh monetary uh or military
uh that they need
the honorable leader of the opposition
to canada
ukraine
is
[Applause]
foreign
my
mr speaker we saw some really hateful
and disturbing images coming out of the
convoy in ottawa this past weekend we
saw the nazi flag being flown the
confederate flag being flown and instead
of denouncing and making it clear that
this type of hate has no place in canada
the leader of the official opposition
and his conservative mps
left the door open to this type of heat
in canada
what is the prime minister going to do
to tackle the rise of online hate so we
can build a better future for our kids
right honorable prime minister
i thank the leader of the ndp for
bringing up this important issue
obviously uh like him we
vigorously condemn the hatred the
intolerance that we've seen in the
streets of ottawa over the past past
number of days we know all canadians are
frustrated all canadians are tired of
this pandemic but the vast majority of
canadians know that listening to science
getting vaccinated continuing to be
there for each other with respect and
openness is the best and really only way
through this pandemic that's what we'll
stay focused on
normal member for burnaby south africa
cementing
[Music]
mr speaker the government of ukraine has
requested lethal defensive weapons from
this government many of our allies
including the united states the united
kingdom poland and the czech republic
all have granted this request and have
supplied lethal defensive weapons the
prime minister has refused this request
why the honorable minister of foreign
affairs
thank you mr speaker when i was in
ukraine a week ago
president zielinski made one ask
to make sure that we would help by
offering a sovereign loan to the ukraine
government to make sure to deal with
economic and stability
three days later we provided 120 million
dollars in sovereign loans
what i heard from the national guard on
site in ukraine is they needed more
support in terms of military training a
week later we extended and expanded
operation unifier
the honourable member for wellington
halton hills mr speaker
diplomacy not backed by credible threats
of the use of military force is nothing
more than empty talk and rhetoric
canada should be joining our other
democratic allies and working in a
multilateral fashion with our nato
partners
to to grant ukraine's request and
provide lethal defensive weapons
when will this government quit being so
naive
about its foreign policy
and ensure that it counters the threats
coming from authoritarian regimes like
russia
mr speaker we're steadfast in supporting
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity let me quote nato secretary
general stoltenberg
canada is one of the league countries in
nato when it comes to providing support
for ukraine he also said there are not
many countries at equal level of efforts
doing as much as canada will continue to
work with our nato allies and make sure
that the situation de-escalates
[Applause]
foreign
is
yes
is
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
mr speaker the russians are ready for
war with ukraine
they've moved over one hundred thousand
troops surrounding ukraine's borders the
russians have moved blood supplies to
their field hospitals this government
has pulled back our op unifier trainers
west of the dinipra river
can the minister tell this parliament if
that means the government considers a
diplomatic solution unlikely and a
russian invasion of ukraine is now
imminent great question honorable
minister of foreign affairs
obviously we take the threat of a
further russian invasion very seriously
and that's why there are two paths to
stop
to stop russia to further invade ukraine
the first one is the diplomatic one and
that's why we're writing we're
working sorry with nato u.s and normandy
format which is french and germany but
also we're working on deterrence that's
why also we extended and expanding it's
expanded operation unifier and also we
have prepared a an array of uh different
economic sanctions against russia should
they further invade thank you
remember south surrey white rocks mr
speaker ukraine will likely be the scene
of a large conventional ground war
we have watched this russian military
buildup in belarus russia dunbas and
crimea since the russians have had
exercises last september the government
had months to prepare a robust military
aid package to ukraine
when will the minister of defense prove
uh
sorry when will the minister of defense
provide the lethal weapons that ukraine
needs
now
the honorable minister
as mentioned before
mr speaker we've already answered the
call on the part of the ukrainian
government by expanding and extending
operation unifier i was there a week ago
and met with the military the canadian
armed forces on site which comes from
valkerti right now quebec city and i saw
on the ground how much the national
guard is thankful to canadians to make
sure that we're providing the right
support to the military and the national
guard and we've trained more than 30 000
national guards and armed forces in
ukraine since 2014. thank you
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
is
[Applause]
foreign
ministry
mr speaker as my uh honorable holly had
mentioned the covenanting pandemic does
not recognize borders and will only be
overcome through a coordinated global
action this is why canada stepped up um
mr speaker we are committed to
donating the equivalent of at least 200
million covet 19 vaccines we are
committed to supporting the equitable
global access to cover 19 vaccines this
includes therapeutics and diagnosis as
well
yes
a
foreign
[Applause]
mr speaker as we stated canada is
stepping up to provide
vaccines for the global community that's
why our government committed 2.6 million
dollars in commitment to the coven 19
response which includes 1.3 billion for
the uh macd accelerator of which 545
million is for kovacs over 740 million
is for humanitarian and development as
assistant mr speaker i could not agree
more with with the member that all of us
in the world need to be vaccinated for
for all of us to be safe thank you
the honourable member for portage lisker
mr speaker all canadians want to see a
leader who will work to heal rifts not
further divide a leader who will listen
even to those voices he might not agree
with the leader who will work to
understand not dismiss name call and
gaslight contrary to some there are
thousands of passionate patriotic and
peaceful canadians on the hill right now
who just want to be heard will the prime
minister extend an olive branch and will
he listen
the honourable minister for public
safety mr speaker i think we all uh
support free speech in this house but
there's a big difference between free
speech and inciting hatred inciting
violence desecrating war memorials mr
speaker and i would hope my honorable
paulie would denounce that in the
clearest terms mr speaker those radical
leaders are not really interested in
free speech because they want to pretend
as those vaccines don't work on this
side of the house we know vaccines work
that's the gateway to freedom and this
government will do everything that we
can to get there thank you mr speaker
member for portage lisker of course we
all condemn hateful and destructive acts
by a few at any protest
whether it's beheading the statue of
queen victoria in manitoba tearing down
the statue of sir johnny in montreal or
putting flags on terry fox whether it's
burning churches whether it's wearing
blackface whether it's hezbollah legs or
nazi flakes we all condemn it but i'm
not
[Applause]
the honorable minister of public safety
mr speaker let's be abundantly clear
that those individuals have called for
the incitement of violence to overthrow
this government who have caused
significant disruption by flagrantly
ignoring public healthcare measures that
have forced shops and businesses to
close that have desecrated war memorials
are not interested in free speech
they're not interested in discourse and
they're certainly not interested in
advancing our way out of this pandemic
mr speaker this government will always
listen to those who want to have a
robust debate about public health care
measures but we have to draw a bright
line between those who are interested in
that debate and those who are not
[Music]
reported to this guy
that minister is not telling the truth
and it's shameful to see what he is
doing
accusing canadians of being
order order
order
i think both sides
are very
truthful in saying what they say whether
they agree with it or not is something
that is another story but calling
someone who's telling well basically
calling them a name or accusing them of
something is not permitted in the house
i'll let the honorable member for
portage lister start from the top and
i'm sure she'll ask the question uh
correctly mr speaker and i apologize
that that minister is misleading
canadians i do get very defensive of
canadians who are outside today
patriotic peace-loving canadians who are
called misogynists and racist by the
prime minister
so again i will ask the prime minister
who may i remind this house war black
face on more times than he can remember
apologize to the peace-loving patriotic
canadians who are outside right now just
asking to be heard will he speak
the honorable government house leader
thank you mr speaker i think this is a
moment uh where we have to acknowledge
that the protests that have occurred
have made their point and i would ask
the member opposite to encourage the
people that are outside to continue in a
way that is peaceful that moves beyond
what we have seen ottawa is being
paralyzed right now we're seeing imagery
that's not appropriate
i'm going to ask the honorable minister
to hold on for a second
because i
i'm sure the honorable member for
portage lisker wants to hear an answer
to the questions he asks
uh no let the honorable minister
continue from where he left from where
he left off just say this mr speaker i
was in opposition i was in opposition
for about seven years and there were
times where i was overheated in my
rhetoric there were moments where i got
too carried away with what i believed
passionately at the time there is a
moment where we need to de-escalate
there's a moment where we need to bring
it down and i'm asking the members
opposite instead of going outside with
these protests
the honorable member for north island
powell river
mr speaker canadians are struggling the
costs of groceries are going up gas and
heating are getting more and more
expensive and the price of housing is
soaring in a recent poll 60 of canadians
said they were having difficulty feeding
their families liberals are not making
it better for canadians especially
vulnerable seniors who are being told
that they must wait months longer for
their gis payment when will this
government help hardworking canadians
who are struggling every day just to get
by
the honorable deputy prime minister
mr speaker i would like to thank the
member opposite for her important
question and we absolutely appreciate
that there are many canadians
particularly vulnerable seniors facing
affordability challenges
in the fall economic update
we presented our government's plan to
support those seniors with a one-time
payment
we will be there for those seniors who
need our support and i want to thank and
congratulate all the canadians who are
behind canada's very robust economic
recovery from the kovig recession
the honorable member for elmwood to
transcona
well thank you very much mr speaker and
the the problem with that answer just as
the problem with the minister's
announcement in the fall economic
statement
is that it does not in any way do
justice to the urgency
of those seniors that have lost their
home now because the government decided
to claw back their guaranteed income
supplement
and aren't getting any relief so they're
out on the street they're freezing in
the cold we've heard reports of people
have already lost their life and the
fact of the matter is is that waiting
until may isn't good enough it's why we
join with campaign 2000 to call for an
emergency payment for those people and
also to make sure that there's a fund to
get them housed right away not in may so
when the honorable
minister mr speaker i think we can all
agree just how challenging this pandemic
has been on senior particularly those
most vulnerable and that is why mr
speaker we worked extremely hard to
strengthen income security for seniors
including the increases to the gis that
has helped over 900 000 low-income
seniors mr speaker we also know seniors
who access inc income supports uh
because they needed it during this
crisis and they shouldn't be penalized
for it now and that's why we're making a
major investment through a one-time
payment for those seniors effective
we've always been there for mr for
seniors mr speaker will always continue
to have their backs thank you
the honourable member for
mississauga-malton
constituents in mississauga-malton are
worried about the rising cost of housing
they want to see federal leadership to
create more affordable housing
unfortunately while our government
delivers that leadership through the
national housing strategy conservative
party members continued to repeat
disinformation about a non-existent home
equity tax in right-wing media last week
can the minister of housing and
diversity and inclusion please set the
record straight again in this house on
the conservative disinformation about a
home equity tax
minister of housing
thank you mr speaker i want to thank the
member of for mississauga molten for his
important question and his advocacy on
affordable housing and i want to welcome
the opportunity to remind those
spreading misinformation that our
government is not considering charging
capital gains or certain taxes on
primary residences and any suggestion
otherwise including from the
conservative party is absolutely false
so while they continue to make up claims
we will focus on making sure that each
and every canadian has access to a safe
and affordable place to call home thank
you mr speaker
the honorable member for carlton
just because
the prime minister dressed up in racist
costumes so many times he can't remember
them all
doesn't mean every single liberal is a
racist
just because the prime minister had
tried to help a corporation avoid
prosecution after it stole from some of
africa's poorest people
doesn't mean all liberals are racist
just because about a half dozen liberal
mps who are racial minorities have
complained about his treatment of them
does not mean
that all liberals are racist
that is guilt by association why doesn't
the prime minister often said for
personal responsibility
[Applause]
mr speaker i hope that i've been clear
in all of my comments that i respect the
honorable colleagues on the other side
just as i believe they respect the
colleagues that are on this side and the
work that we do and the people that we
are there are times in our political
discourse where we see things that are
abhorrent and all i would actually
equally call it out when i saw swastikas
on the street when i saw what had
happened it's time to move on and what i
would ask is instead of trying to
inflame the situation let us de-escalate
the situation let us work together to
find a way to stop the walk down that is
happening of this city and so that
citizens can move forward with their
lives and any legitimate grievances can
be fairly heard
the honorable member for carlton
[Music]
will mr speaker i agree we should always
call out evil symbols and the
individuals who are individually
responsible for putting them up i
remember a january 18 january 2018 event
where the prime minister stared straight
at a swastika and instead of condemning
it said thank you for coming sir
we on this side condemn evil symbols
whenever they are used i do respect that
member i just wish his government
would respect the thousands of people
who are fighting for their livelihoods
right now who are trying to do the best
to get this country back on track
[Applause]
global crisis uh a time when so many are
being uh adversely affected by this
pandemic and our hearts go out to every
one of them the way in which we have
discourse for each other will define
this moment for all of us and to those
that are peacefully protesting i would
ask that their point has been made it's
time to go home and do it a different
way that continuing to lock down this
city and continuing to do what's
happening it is deeply disturbing for
canadians to see the way that this city
and our symbols are being treated and i
would ask the conservatives to also join
with us to ask that they go home and
let's do this responsibly let's have
responsible dialogue i respect the
member opposite let's do this the right
way
the honorable member for carlton
well the problem is they've no they've
shown no respect for the people this
country
right now is like a raw nerve and the
prime minister is jumping up and down on
it again and again with his inflammatory
record rhetoric we're talking about
people who have 14 year old kids that
are suicidal after two years of
lockdowns i just spoke to a waitress
whose business was wiped out by
lockdowns i'm talking to truckers who've
been who've been serving food on our
plates throughout this and these are the
very people honest hard-working shirt
off your back type of people that this
prime minister keeps attacking
the honorable government
we'll wait to start the time okay very
good please mr speaker again i i
encourage the member um to to just think
about if he's talking about
de-escalating and having civil discourse
uh his tone and how he's approaching
this issue this is a time that is
incredibly delicate we are in a moment
where there is a raw nerve that is being
touched how we talk to each other mr
speaker how we deal with one another i
i'm going to interrupt the honorable
government house leader and just wait
till everything calms down a moment and
that a lot of them start from the top
because i'm sorry i didn't have a chance
to hear it all and i'm sure the
honourable member from carleton asked a
question he wanted to answer to and he
wants wants to hear it and we're just
not hearing anything because of the
noise the honourable government house
leader please proceed i have an instinct
and that instinct is that canadians
expect us
today when they're seeing what's
happened over this weekend to watch the
dialogue in this chamber be as
respectful as possible for us to dial
down our rhetoric and our language for
us to engage one another and find an
off-ramp from the escalation that has
occurred because this is not healthy in
a healthy democracy we have respectful
debates that don't involve some of the
things that we've seen and all i'm
asking for is for us to engage in a
constructive way so if we could attempt
in this place in this hour to be equal
to that i hope that we can move forward
on that basis
for carlton well i couldn't agree more
and mr speaker i was out of an overpass
as the truckers went by and what i saw
were cheerful
patriotic optimistic canadians who want
their freedom back and want their
livelihoods back and they're standing up
for their fellow canadians the 60 of
families who fear they can't feed
themselves the 28 year old kid living in
mom's basement because he can't afford a
home the small businessman wiped out by
endless lockdowns by incompetent
politicians these are the people that
are standing up and fighting for their
livelihoods and their freedom why won't
the government finally stand with them
a fundamental difference mr speaker i
have a fundamental difference in that is
that i don't believe that my enemy is
across the aisle i believe that our
enemy is this pandemic and that our
enemy is ending this pandemic and
getting everybody uh to get vaccinated
and to move forward in a way where the
concerns that he's talking about being
affected by a global crisis means that
they are supported this is a time of
collective trauma it requires us to be
compassionate to work with another and
understand that our common enemy is the
virus and not one another
[Applause]
it's committing genocide against its own
people
we shouldn't do
this we decided to encourage the game to
be held in china
for the first time
[Applause]
decided to send their athletes to
participate in the chinese the
government said
coherent messages
investigating
[Music]
against the weaker people very seriously
and that is
to investigate
that's not true on the contrary we want
to shed full light on this issue because
it's very concerning thank you very much
lake country
mr speaker last month the associate
finance minister said that when it came
to payroll tax hikes that quote
businesses
can afford this
how completely out of touch is this
comment with small businesses
considering they went ahead with these
tax hikes despite 30-year record high
inflation rates we have to assume this
government believes that businesses can
afford these as well so to the minister
how historically high do inflation rates
have to be before this government stops
increasing taxes on small businesses
[Applause]
you know mr speaker when it comes to
supporting small businesses it is a bit
rich of the conservatives to presume to
offer our government any advice at all
after all
before christmas when the omicron wave
was rising it was these conservatives
who opposed bill c-2
a bill which included a lockdown
insurance policy for small businesses
and canadians the conservatives voted
against it thank goodness they failed
otherwise our small businesses today
would have no support
the honourable member for hastings linux
and addington
mr speaker
record inflation
coupled with this government's brutal
gis clawback has financially crippled
many of canada's hard-working seniors
forced to spend their golden years in
the labor market just to make ends meet
our vulnerable seniors need to know that
ottawa is listening
that is why our conservative opposition
called on this government to reverse the
cpp tax hike
mr speaker when will this government
stand up
rise up lean in to canada's hard-working
seniors and help them meet their base
honorable
minister
worked all their lives and they deserve
to feel safe and financially secure
later in their life that is why mr
speaker our government is delivering on
our promise to increase the oas by 10
percent for those 75 and older
strengthening the support for all
canadians later in life since 2015 mr
speaker we have restored the age of
eligibility for oas to 65. we have
increased the gis for single seniors and
strengthened the cpp during the pandemic
we provided direct and immediate support
for seniors mr speaker and as always we
will be there for them
the honourable member for brantford
brandt mr speaker with inflation
reaching a 30-year high the government
continues to hurt canadians with its
poor economic policies
nearly 60 percent of people are finding
it difficult to feed their families and
if that's not bad enough the government
raised its cpp tax on canadians an extra
seven hundred dollars coming out of
family's paychecks now this may mean
nothing to this prime minister but it
matters to everybody else
when will the government reverse its cpp
tax and stop penalizing hard-working
families
the honorable
deputy prime minister mr speaker the
conservatives continue to irresponsibly
perpetuate a false economic narrative
and talk down the canadian economy
the reality is that canada is resilient
and our economy is robustly recovering
from the coveted recession in q3 our gdp
grew by 5.4
that was beating the us japan the uk and
australia we have recovered 108 of jobs
lost to the pandemic compared to just 84
in the u.s and we had in november a
trade surplus at a 13-year high
the honorable member for king's hands
you see the president on the psalm mr
speaker
the minister of the environment and
climate change announced a consultation
process
on our new climate commitments
the minister
our government
thank you mr
my
speaker
for his ongoing efforts
[Music]
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
many in canada's labor force are senior
citizens
struggling to get by
many seniors are forced to work beyond
the retirement age
to no fault of their own the cpp tax
hike has added insult to injury to our
seniors who have worked hard their whole
life
the out-of-control inflation has many
working seniors feeling like retirement
is a dream
they will never
have the ability to experience
when will this government reverse the
cpp heights for our seniors thank you
the honorable minister
speaker since 2015 our government has
been strengthening retirement support
for seniors today and for future
retirees we have built a strong social
net and pension system that all
canadians mr speaker can be proud of we
have enhanced the cpp the oas and raised
gis for single seniors that has helped
900 000 low-income single seniors mr
speaker we're helping investing in
services such as 70 million dollars for
new horizons for seniors program
billions into home care mr speaker we're
going to make sure that seniors now and
into the future have all the supports
that they need thank you
member for edmonton riverbend
mr speaker cmhc is a federal agency
funded by this housing minister using
taxpayer dollars so recently cmhc funds
a study that determine the best course
of action tax canadian homeowners more
why should canadians be concerned about
this mr speaker because this government
continues to float the idea of adding
more taxes on canadian homeowners on
this side of the house mr speaker we are
a hundred percent against this tax why
is this minister continue to support the
idea of adding more taxes on canadian
homeowners
[Applause]
it gives me another opportunity to once
again state categorically that our
government is not considering charging
capital gains or surge taxes on primary
residences we've said this time and time
again in the house of commons and in the
public sphere and the party opposite
continues to engage in misinformation
we're busy focused on the work of
ensuring that each and every canadian
has a safe and affordable place to go
we want our businesses to believe in the
future of our country
and continue operating their businesses
[Applause]
once again
and we establish measures to help and
support small businesses
in canada
the conservatives were against such
measures
can the minister of transport please
share with the house the steps our
government is taking to safeguard the
health of canadians and canada's air
transportation system thank you
honourable minister of transport
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
thank my colleague for a question our
government is committed to the public
health
of our
our citizens mr speaker our leadership
requires belief in science leadership
also requires resolve and we are
resolute to doing everything we can to
protect the health and safety of
canadians that's why we've implemented
measures including requiring travelers
to be fully vaccinated and any
allegations of violations of our public
health measures will be investigated
fully by transport canada mr speaker
thank you very
much the honourable member for windsor
west
mr speaker like many other frontline
workers grocery store workers have put
their health at risk to make sure
canadians have been able to get the
essentials that they need with covet 19
cases high it's absolutely essential
that they are treated and compensated
fairly for the work that they do big
grocery store chains won't do the right
thing on their own and restore the hero
pay they had promised they even take
government handouts to pay their rich
ceos if the liberals won't stand up for
these workers will they at least
guarantee that these fat cats won't
continue to get taxpayer subsidized
money especially when they promise to
make this happen what will the minister
do
the honourable deputy prime minister uh
thank you very much mr speaker and i
would like to thank the member opposite
for reminding us yet again that covid
has really shown us who are the truly
essential workers in our economy and
that very much includes frontline
workers in places like grocery stores
our government is very pleased to have
been able to put measures in place
throughout coven to support these
workers including measures like paid
sick leave including measures like
government support for people who need
to take time off if a loved one is sick
and of course the increase in the canada
workers benefit absolutely the honorable
member for kitchener center
mr speaker earlier this month over 400
climate scientists and scholars
co-signed a letter calling on the
federal government to step back from its
plan to introduce another fossil fuel
subsidy a new tax credit for carbon
capture and storage
as stated in their letter despite
decades of research carbon captures
neither economically sound nor proven at
scale
this proposal would only divert
resources away from proven and
cost-effective solutions like renewable
energy and electrification
can the minister confirm they will
listen to scientists and scrap this
proposed new subsidy
the honorable minister
the honorable minister of the
environment
thank you very much mr speaker and thank
you to my honorable colleague for his
question
we have to look at every possible
technologies that will help us reduce
greenhouse gas and in fact when it comes
to carbon capture and storage the ipcc
itself produced a report a few years ago
looking at this very technology
saying that we might have to do it
because we won't be able to reduce our
greenhouse gas emissions fast enough to
prevent 1.5 degrees celsius of global
warming mr speaker thank you very much
that's all the time we have
that's all the time we have for question
period today
did you have a no
no point